i really for me to be successful
professionally it was important for me
to find
my meaning of professionally where i
could get meaning from the work that i
do and the reason i say that is because
i really truly believe that
what is best for people
is also best for organizations welcome
to 20-minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders this
episode is all about self leadership
meet tony gamble founder and ceo of
clearview leadership llc
tony brings more than 20 years of
executive experience delivering
impactful leadership and talent
solutions for global organizations he
recently published a new book named
getting it right when it matters most
self leadership for work and life he is
also a contributor for forbes where he
writes on the topics of self leadership
and leading others tony is the president
of clearview leadership which provides
innovative leadership and town
development consulting services to
leaders worldwide
tony gamble welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you doing today
i'm doing great especially for a monday
thanks how are you michael
well thank you for spending uh the early
monday with me and where are you calling
from right now
at chapel hill north carolina
all right from north carolina and we're
going to be talking today tony about
about leadership and not just leadership
you know you're running a company called
clearview leadership and one of the
interesting pieces of work that you're
doing is on self leadership and and what
i'm curious about in these 20 minutes is
to dive deep into what that means for
you for me for everybody around us and
what are the implications of self
leadership and the things that we do
both professionally and personally and
obviously you know thinking more
critically about the world of
entrepreneurship and you know leadership
in the workplace especially as you're
not just leading yourself but you're
leading others what what are what is
that what are the implications of that
and and obviously talk about the book
that you've written so tony a lot of a
lot to talk about today
but tell me a little bit about yourself
and how did you get started thinking
through this idea of leadership in
general
so a little bit about myself i've been
doing this work
working with uh
when i describe the work i do it's in
twofold it's helping others with
self-leadership and leading others and
so
sort of the concepts around that for the
last 20 years i have been i have been
internal with organizations having
responsibility for
the talent development leadership
development talent processes for three
different global organizations
and
from that i've learned some real keys
that make
it important for people to really focus
or maybe actually what are the keys that
really help people succeed in bringing
their best selves to their organizations
and so that's really what my focus has
been on for the last three or four years
in writing this book and also starting
my own organization
amazing okay and so as you're
you know looking now at the journey of
examining leadership and researching it
how do you find it that your perceptive
of what leadership is how did it change
over the years how did you know the
perception of the core of leadership how
did it change
yeah i i think
how it's evolved is i think early in my
career
i think leadership was more for me
focused on
how do i
engage in situations and make the
situation better um and it was really
more externally focused around
leadership and how that thinking has
involve evolved over the years is what
i've learned is
you really can't be successful
with external leadership or leading
others until you focus on leading
yourself first until you really
understand who you are how situations
impact who you are how you bring your
best actions to those and how you
continually grow as a leader because
challenges are going to come and go as a
leader um i have been in so many
situations with leadership where they
were hard i didn't think i had any good
answers to that to the situation i
actually felt they were unfair sometimes
um and that happens with all of us in
leadership
but those situations come and go what
doesn't come and go is who we are we
bring ourselves to all of those
situations and so really my big shift in
leadership was you have to start with
the foundation of self
and self leadership before you can be
effective
as i believe as a leader but also at
work and life um and so that's really
that was a tremendous shift for me
and sort of started me thinking about
what
my primary focus needed to be in
developing leaders
right and so
if we're looking at the self this idea
of the self leader as a part of
you know this this greater idea of at
the end how you interact with the world
what are some non-trivial concepts about
self-leadership that you know i or any
of my friends should be keeping in mind
as we go about our day-to-day and
reacting to all sorts of situations yeah
and that is really important um because
what i understand about successful
leaders is they get
during the harder situations during the
more challenging complex situations they
do better they thrive and the reason
they thrive is because they have this
foundation of self-leadership but the
challenge for me as an educator for me
is someone that focuses on talent and
leadership development the challenge is
there are so many aspects out in the
world today around
around self-leadership around emotional
intelligence around self-awareness
around you know hundreds of assessments
to better know yourself um around
learning agility around um social
intelligence around empathy
around mindfulness there's so many of
these vertical disciplines for people to
have to try to that are all important
for people to have to try and learn and
people don't have the time to do that
people don't have the focus unless
you're in the profession and so what i
really wanted to focus on are what are
the fewest most important things that
leaders need to understand about
self-leadership to be successful and
that's why i really focused time on
creating a self-leadership model that
was practical replicable and based on
research and the model is called the
soar model and soar as in flying not as
in hurt but the sore model that stands
for self
outlook
action
and reflection and within each one of
those we start to look at what is most
important about self-awareness that i
need to have for self-leadership
what is most important that i need to
understand about my outlook in relation
to when i'm engaging with challenging
and important and relational situations
around my perception biases around
emotional agility around managing
threats
um and then
how do i bring my best self to action
right and what we learn in businesses
and homes and relationships is the
primary actions that we have is how we
engage with one another how we
communicate with one another and how do
i bring empathy how do i ask quality
questions how do i engage in harder
conversations and then this r stands for
reflection how do i continually learn
from my practice and my experience and
getting good feedback and reflecting so
i can continually have agility so i can
improve self that brings better outlook
that enables me better actions that i've
learned through reflection again and
it's a cycle and replicable and those
are the foundational pieces of
self-leadership as i defined it in the
book i'm getting it right when it
matters most
how
how can we measure
our ability to exercise on on a model
like sword or or any other model for
that matter when when it comes to
something as
you know as
not theoretical but something that is so
intangible and subjective as a self
leadership how can you know let's say
you as a coach
how do you measure whether somebody is
exerting
good self-leadership or not
yeah i think you're asking a couple of
different questions um and so i want to
be real clear to answer how do you
measure if you're bringing
strong self-leadership to a situation or
how do you measure what self-leadership
is
well let's go with both okay
so measuring what self-leadership is is
it's
what i've learned is i've worked with um
i've worked with mission-driven
technical research-based organizations
my whole life and so within that what
i've learned is i need to stand on the
shoulders of previous research
and
theory and practice to be able to learn
how to work with these leaders because
they they won't they won't work with you
unless you're bringing a foundation of
of social and physical science to them
um and so
what i what we did when we were putting
together this self-leadership model is
there are reams and mountains of
research around emotional intelligence
self-awareness um right
social intelligence empathy
learning agility about the impact of
those things on us being successful
leaders and successful employees and so
the research about the importance of
these concepts is there and what i did
is i was actually
when you um
i really actually spent years going
through all of the
all of the information and through my
practice and working with leaders and
saying what were the fewest most
important concepts that enable people to
be able to bring self-leadership and we
wanted to make it practical and simple
and replicable for people so that's how
we
worked with the model
um your other question is more around
how do you know if you're bringing
effective self leadership to a situation
is that correct
yes yes so with that i think
really
the only thing when you really get when
i'm working with leaders there there is
a plethora of situations that are
challenging that leaders
engage with
but the thing that they always bring is
their self and you know stephen covey
had a model that i really that's
timeless for me it's it's circles of
influence and what he says is you know
there's three levels of influence
things that we can
control fully things that we can
influence and things that we can't
control well what leaders bring to those
situations there's a lot of things that
they can't control and there's a lot of
things they can influence and then
there's a certain amount of things that
they have full control of and the real
center of that is
how they show up are they bringing their
best selves are they are they aligning
their daily actions and intentions to
their best long-term goals and values of
the organization and for themselves
right i think that makes i think that
makes a lot of sense now maybe if it was
perhaps talking about a specific example
of maybe somebody exerting good self
leadership versus somebody who's
exerting that self-leadership at a
specific you know a fork in the road
because obviously we're we're making
thousands of decisions on a daily basis
where
i think that it would be interesting for
me to examine the way different
reactions and different self leadership
would come into play at a given
situation
yeah
i
i'm trying to sort of reflect on your
question a little bit michael and so if
you can if you can restate it real
quickly so i can so i can do a good job
of answering it maybe we can take a
specific example of a decision or an
event that happens and then how
good self-leadership would be shown
versus bad self-leadership so that we
can really distinct
what would be good self-leadership
versus not so good yeah i okay so
my sense is about what good versus bad
self-leadership varies from people but
and let me give be real specific about
right
we all in every situation bring our
unique strengths and weaknesses habits
values lenses goals in relation to that
um and so when we're encountering a
situation
understanding
what our long-term goals are and what
our values are
and making good choices that enable us
to within our values and within the
organization's you know processes and
standards that enable us to show up in a
way that helps us achieve what we want
to achieve um and so i mean what does
that mean it means um practically let's
say i'm in a situation where i don't get
along with my manager
right
it's important it's complex and it's
relational um and so i have two choices
right one is i can change try to change
my manager i can debate and i can argue
but that may serve me short term trying
to win my position but long term if my
if my goals are is to serve the
organization
be an example of a good leader um live
within my values
that is disconnected from
my actions right and so when my actions
are disconnected from my values my
purpose and my strengths and i'm not
making the right choices that is not
exhibiting good self leadership let's
get myself in this uh
put myself in that same example in
demonstrating good self-leadership um
even though that's a hard situation one
that i didn't don't want to address if i
go into that and i am bringing my best
self by understanding how the situation
is impacting my negative emotions how
it's triggering my perception biases how
it enables me to go have an honest
conversation
with that manager about the situation um
trying to align goals that meet for both
of us and then continually reflecting to
bring my best self to that situation
i am focusing more on how i can be
successful and how i can bring my best
self to that situation than trying to
change
the person than trying to change their
values i'm trying to work with them and
controlling what i can to be successful
that makes a lot of sense i want to go
back a little bit to you know some
higher level thinking that that you've
learned over the years because you've
seen a lot of different leaders you've
been thinking critically about this idea
of leadership
what are ways in my day-to-day life that
i can improve my perception of
these types of
of these situations this type of
self-leadership what can i do
whether it's you know active or passive
to improve the way that i will exert
self leadership and bring my best self
to these situations yeah and so i would
start with saying i don't think we can
i can't i i am not capable of
reflecting and being deliberate in every
situation
what i would what i would espouse for
people is
you really need to be deliberate about
how you show up in your important
complex and relational situations
um and so that is when we need to be
more rigorous about how we show up and
so what are some of the keys around that
is you've got to have a foundation of
good self-awareness understanding your
strengths weaknesses values you've got
to understand how
important complex and relational
situations
impact how you view situations your
outlook how does it how do you mitigate
you know wanting to be right how do you
mitigate um
being wrong in situations or are
admitting you don't have all the right
answers how do you navigate situations
when you're feeling lost are you feeling
uncertain are you feeling um and so this
is all around emotional regulation
emotional agility understanding your
emotions and working past them and
understanding what they mean but they're
they don't define you and then moving
forward with
choices around action that align with
your values and your overall purpose and
then the last piece the best way to
learn is not in a classroom it's through
practice and reflection and feedback
practice reflection and feedback so when
i think about how i would say people
need to move forward to be more
effective with self-leadership those are
some of the foundational components and
that's what we're trying to put together
in this thor model is what are the
fewest most important things that enable
you to succeed in your important complex
and relational moments
that makes a lot of sense now i want you
to go back a little bit to your
childhood before you even think about
leadership what what really excites you
what really fascinates you as a kid
yeah for me michael it was
it was really relationships and my
relationships with my friends i was uh
i
i am a learner that needs application
for learning so for me school was not
that interesting growing up but my
relationships with my friends were and
how that played out is i am still my
best friends are the friends that i grew
up with still
many years later and we don't live in
the same locations but that was really
what was most interesting to me growing
up
wow
i love that and if you had to look today
at
you know what inspires you and obviously
you know the the note about your friends
i think that speaks a lot to the way
that you're doing today but what is
what is something that really inspires
you on a day-to-day basis to continue
doing what you're doing
yeah what inspires me on a day-to-day
basis is
a couple of things
my
i really for me to be successful
professionally it was important for me
to find
my meaning of
professionally where i could get meaning
from the work that i do and the reason i
say that is because
i really truly believe that
what is best for people
is also best for organizations
now
what so what inspires me and what what
is is important to me is working with
people in a manner that enables them to
bring their best selves to their working
environment that's what inspires me
that's what gets me going that's what i
enjoy
doing now there are some situations that
organizations and actually i do work
design and i have done work design where
we've had to let people go from an
organization
and the truth was there's hard decisions
right the decisions are around right
doing what's best for the whole and some
people having to leave the organization
i still believe doing that in an
empathic
way
that honors people and includes people
in a in a way that you can is the best
way for people to be successful and
taking care of the people that aren't
that are having to transition or no
longer have a place there in the best
possible way you can is still best for
the company um and so doing what is best
for people is i always correlated and
believe that it's also what's best for
organizations
i love that and if you have to choose a
few words that you would use to describe
yourself what would those be
um to describe myself i'm
action-oriented
oriented i am uh i am relationship
oriented which you've probably been able
to tell through this and i'm very
reflective 100
and i'm very reflected in that i
understand as a leader that i need to do
two things i need to get results and i
need to build strong relationships and
being aware of that continuum and
understanding how i navigate that
continuum is very important for the work
that i do
tony thank you very very much for these
20 minutes i really really appreciate it
thank you for the inspiration and thank
you for you know helping people be
better leaders both to others and to
themselves and to their organizations
and stay safe and stay healthy yeah
michael thank you i appreciate your time
and uh allowing me to be a part of your
platform thanks
you